what up space cowboy goes in here for
anime uproar and today we're going to be
talking about some demon slayer facts I
plan to do additional fact videos for
specific characters if you enjoy it this
one so definitely let me know if that's
something you'd like to see in the
comments also comment on which
characters you'd want to see covered the
most if you want to keep seeing the even
static content on this channel make sure
to smash that like button to let me know
and if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and ring that notification bell so you
actually get notified when new videos
drop now without further ado let's jump
into it fact number one Demon Slayer
commits no Yaiba was first published in
Weekly Shonen Jump On February 16 2016
weekly shonen jump is the best-selling
manga magazine and one of the
longest-running
massively successful manga like
Dragonball one-piece and Naruto were all
published and Weekly Shonen Jump thus
the fact that demon slayer could even
maintain a spot in such a competitive
magazine for over three years shows how
popular it is as of the time of writing
demon slayer has sixteen volumes
published in japan and 170 chapters have
been released however if you've been
reading manga for a while you know that
it takes a long time for the volumes to
be officially translated and released in
English right now you can pre-order the
eighth volume on amazon.com fact number
two the mangaka who created demons there
is oil haru gotaga she joins other
female mangakas who have managed to
create amazing and popular Shonen manga
interestingly enough sho nough means boy
Shonen manga are primarily targeted
toward a certain demographic namely
towards boys between the ages of 12 and
18 it is the most popular form of manga
however just because Shonen manga are
primarily targeted towards boys it
doesn't mean that only men draw them in
fact rumiko takahashi created inuyasha a
series that felt a lot like demon slayer
because it was also heavily influenced
by japanese folklore inuyasha was
actually my favorite anime when i first
watched as a kid another one of my
favorite anime Full Metal Alchemist was
also created by a female manga called
Hyuna mu Arakawa evidently koi Haru is
in good company the 31 year old manga
Kai usually draws herself as a crocodile
with glasses and her mom
in 2013 at the age of 24 coyotl was one
of the recipients of the 70th the jump
treasure newcomer manga awards her
one-shot manga about demon slang called
Peggotty Gotti was published the demon
Sara we know today was loosely inspired
by this first work but before demon se
was serialized koi Yahoo published some
other Wan shots which leads us to our
next FAQ FAQ number three one of the one
shots that Koyo Haru published before
demon slayer was called hai anyone knows
exact it was published in Weekly Shonen
Jump in 2015
it was about a character named zigzag
who could remove curses using
plant-based powers what really struck me
about this manga is how different it is
from demon slayer in addition to taking
place in modern times rather than in the
past the story features a protagonist
that is almost a complete opposite of
demon slayer protagonist tan Jiro the
main character wanted to use curses to
kill people and benefit himself before
he himself got cursed after getting
cursed he could no longer use his powers
for selfish means as a result he has to
help remove curses but he doesn't act
like he enjoys helping people in fact he
usually complains and emphasizes the
fact that people should help themselves
and not seek help from others he even
initially refused to help an old lady
carry her bags something that ton Jiro
would offer to do before being asked
this seeming 180 switch reminds me of
how the black claw creator Tabata
initially had a manga called hungry
Joker with a quieter less innocent main
character however that manga was
canceled and Tabata realized that he
would have more success with a louder
pure hearted and optimistic protagonist
and thus hasta was born it seems like
the pure-hearted tan judo was also the
result of trial and error fact number 4
here's an interesting note on the
Japanese title of demon slayer komatsuna
Yaiba literally translates to demon
slang blade so it gives us more
information than the English title demon
slayer the word blade in the title nods
to the niche hidden blade which is a
special color-changing blade and demon
slayer that can actually kill demons who
would simply regenerate otherwise the
word blade also nods to the importance
of swordsmanship in the series fact
number 5 the anime series 4 demon slayer
premiered on April 6 2009 teen so far as
far as the first season goes
funny episodes have been released out of
26 as of now and they haven't even
gotten to chapter 50 yet as I mentioned
before there are 170 chapters out right
now so if we continue to follow this
pace we should already have enough manga
material for roughly another two seasons
this is good news for people like me who
are hooked and want the upcoming anime
seasons to come out as soon as possible
the demon slayer anime has absolutely
beautiful animation and we have the
Japanese animation studio who felt able
to thank for that
they were behind the animated series
fate/zero which also stunned me when i
saw its visual beauty so you can bet
this studio has the talent to deliver a
breathtaking experience no pun intended
you might talk a Hashi a producer from
Aniplex a company that helped produce
demon slayer let's interview during
Anime Expo he said that as far as the
creative side is concerned he doesn't
need to do much because the studio who
folds table does such an amazing job he
said that the original manga is included
in the animation process and asked about
the script and character designs finally
the studio staff is willing to work
really hard and doesn't take any
shortcuts they work and rework some
scenes many times in order to capture
the powerful scenes from the manga the
director Haru osoto Zaki has worked on
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood in the
past one of my favorite anime of all
time and I'm the Cowboy Bebop film so it
appears like as far as the enemy goes
demon slayers definitely in good hands
fact number 6 let's talk about demon
Slayers popularity for this fact otaku
mode com had a popularity poll for
spring 2019 anime and demon slayer came
in 6th place it was also a popular manga
from Weekly Shonen Jump so there was
definitely hype around it in 2017
Japanese bookstore employees
ranked it in 14th place on a list of the
top 15 recommended manga kono manga gas
Sugoi revealed their list of the top 20
manga 2018 for male readers and demon
slayer came in 19th place obviously many
manga came ahead of demon slayer like
dr. stone and promised neverland which
came in first but nonetheless it is
impressive that demon slayer made the
cuts so demon slayer was definitely not
clouded by obscurity but it does seem
like its popularity really exploded
recently with the
anime adaptation and especially with the
release of episode 19 of the anime they
got the point where the famous twitch
streamer ninja who has over 4.7 million
followers on Twitter tweeted that demon
sir might be his favorite anime of all
time
demon slayer was trending on twitter
internationally the episode had a strong
97.5% high approval rating on niconico
and the anime currently has an 8.8
rating on IMDB I could say that I myself
felt like it was the best anime episode
I've seen in a while and I had to make a
post about it on Instagram at Anime
uproar immediately after watching it
even the mangaka was so overwhelmed by
the episode that she cried after
watching it she said that the production
crew nailed it and you can't really get
a better compliment than that while
working on an anime I've read ahead in
the manga and I can honestly say that
Demon Slayer gets even better as long as
the animation team keeps working this
hard and keeps producing this quality of
work I believe that the Messiah will
only get more popular fact number 7 next
let's take a look at the character
popularity poll to see how the Demon
Slayer characters stack up to each other
in regards to popularity the manly man
with the feminine face
eNOS gay got in fifth place with 1977
votes the stoic gear got in fourth place
with 2190 votes the demonically cute met
Zuko got third place for three thousand
three hundred 19 votes the fearful Zenit
Suh got second place with four thousand
two hundred nine nine votes
lastly tan judo came in first place with
six thousand seven hundred forty-two
votes that's quite the wide margin
between first and second place so it
goes to show just how lovable the
kind-hearted protagonist of Demon Slayer
is it's not always the case that the
protagonist
takes first place if you look at Naruto
or attack on Titan often other
characters like a coffee or Levi's when
the popularity polls so the fact that
ton zero one shows that the mangaka did
a great job of creating a protagonist
that we can't help but like and root for
fact number eight in the manga Koyo haru
includes bonus manga material where the
characters from demons there are normal
high school students rather than demon
hunters for instance is any to is a
member of the problem schools
whirls committee although he doesn't
want to be it's kind of like how he's a
Demon Slayer even though he often
complains about it Tantra is as nice as
ever even while he breaks the note
earrings rule at school he apologizes
and breaks the rules in a very polite
manner rather than bamboo Messick ou can
be seen holding bread in her mouth
instead in escaped bullies any tzu while
Tomioka GU is a school teacher who hits
as any two because he thinks he dyed his
hair blond like a delinquent these
stories offer some great comedic relief
between manga chapters and I always look
forward to seeing what kind of high
school students different characters and
demons would make fact number 9 let's
talk about demons and Japanese folklore
for this fact although the monsters are
called demons in English they're
actually inspired by the figure of the
Oni from Japanese folklore
although Koyo Haru puts her own spin on
the concept her Oni do share some traits
with the Oni of mythology o near
humanoid creatures who usually have one
or multiple horns sharp claws and wild
hair even Mexico as a more humane Oni is
eventually shown with all three a horn
sharp claws and wild hair only are also
known for their strength intelligence
and powerful magic all characteristics
that are possessed by the Oni of demon
slayer like in Demon Slayer only can be
sometimes good and sometimes bad
although most demons in Demon Slayer
appear to be bad at least at first there
are some good demons including Nezu KO
who do not want to hurt humans
female-only can even be quite beautiful
and we see that in Demon Slayer
especially when we get to the red-light
district arc the Oni Docky is one of the
hottest characters in anime the
similarities go on but I just wanted to
point out some of the major ones that
stood out to me in the end the monsters
in Demon Slayer are referenced to very
specific figures in Japanese folklore
and to an extent simply translating Oni
as demons does that fact that this
service fact number 10 lastly I wanted
to point out that on TV tropes or you
can find an exhaustive list of all of
the tropes used in the demon slayer
manga I read the whole list and it's
very insightful for example in auskey is
an example of the be shown and trope
vishen n is a beautiful boy that
possesses feminine physical trait
it is not uncommon for these characters
to be mistaken for woman and they
sometimes even use their feminine looks
to their advantage
despite his filthy bore mask and muscles
eNOS gay has such a feminine face that
Zenit su is completely shocked when he
sees it and searched the question
whether or not he's actually a girl and
later his feminine face is used to his
advantage in the manga but we won't get
into that at this point since I don't
want to spoil anime only fans another
trope that is present in demon slayer is
the trope of calling her attacks as in
most Ronin instead of attacking in
silence and taking the enemy by surprise
the demon slayers and the demons scream
out their moves most of the time in real
life this would not be smart you not
only let your enemy know that you're
attacking but if they know enough about
your fighting style you're even
revealing exactly how you're gonna
attack nevertheless it's a trope in
Shonen manga that works to get readers
excited and hyped up and it definitely
works I'm sure I'm not the only one here
who tried to launch kamehameha and my
friends in demon slayer the demon
hunters announced their breath styles
and the demons announced their blood
demon arts and that is it for today's
video I'm really enjoying demon slayer
so I'd love to make more videos if you
want to see more if you did enjoy this
video make sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification belt so you actually get
notified when a new video comes out
leave suggestions for future fact videos
and other demon slayer videos in the
comments follow us on instagram and
twitter at anime uproar for more anime
greatness a big thank you goes to our
patrons over on patreon who help make
videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings out
just an angel Cruz and other one tier
patrons the ones who stay on top all
clans baby Rey a17 ffvp Steven and Radha
allo lon autumn Maddy Mac 239 makoto-kun
and keelon and the patrons who transcend
greatness itself Regan Harrison and Lord
knocks on door the chosen few who have
been acknowledged by Lord we go himself
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon calm
an Emir or and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your
featured in future videos alongside
these demon slayers right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin
n until next time see you space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]